exponential constitutional treatment by
reduction so the occasion of this
workshop made me think a little bit
about what had made the most difference
in my life computationally because the
computational challenges workshop and
thinking back over things I have worked
on a lot of things to work on parallel
learning I've worked on tempo complexity
bounds I think what really made the
biggest difference was thinking to think
about machine learning in a reduction
way and in doing this there's been
probably three cases where I came up
with algorithms which are kind of an
exponential improvement on on what we
knew how to do in a semi optimal way
using reductions so I'm going to talk
about this is not about any particular
result this is more of a forest talk
than a tree talk but let's just start
with kind of where we are
so the field right now is rain pea Racal
to hear about advances in speech
recognition
imagenet deep learning literal machine
translation these are all fun things but
they're not things that you are being
really driven by theory right now and
when this is happening it's kind of a
question about what what you would be
thinking about three wise now a lot of
different theories that exist in machine
learning so let's think a little bit
about what happens with reduction so let
me go through some problems that I've
worked on one of them is contextual
bandits so it will connectional bandits
what happens is you have some features
you choose an action and then you see
some reward and now your goal is to
learn a good policy for choosing actions
given the context and okay so if it's a
good problem you did you'd imagine that
this is the real-world problem in many
ways we actually are doing personalized
news on MSN using this kind of approach
and you know it made a huge difference
so
in terms of empirical results we did a
reduction trying to figure out how to
back up a little bit for this kind of
setting the first result that people
know about was I think the exp for paper
which I think was first published in
1995 and it was it's a pretty amazing
paper but the running time if you want
to compete with a set of policies is
something like order number of policies
which is completely catastrophic in a
kind of real world application right so
consider a numerating every possible
decision tree and then try to compete
with that set okay so we wanted to make
things fast we made things fast this is
the results from the mini monster paper
so its title is taming the monster we
compared epsilon greedy is a very simple
exploration algorithm which is
suboptimal sophistical e this is kind of
a heuristic that people use where they
kind of train multiple different
algorithms and what multiplies this is
the different items differing by
bootstrap sampling and then you can use
that the inducer distribution over
actions that you explore from it's
rather slow comparison because it's a
train when different learning algorithms
you can use lynnie CB which is sort of
terrible computationally because you
have to do some sort of matrix inversion
you can approximate that we did
approximate it maybe you could
proximately harder than we did but as
you approximate your performance tends
to get worse you could run our algorithm
which was relatively fast and then
because this was actually a supervisor
tip that we were only probing for the
loss so whichever action we took you get
your unsupervised learning on the same
data set in the same way and then you
would see that you know we're almost
getting the same performance of
supervised learning except with only
contextual bandit feedback
so that's a nice result you can think
about the offline context about I think
which is similar to this except we're
not controlling the exploration we're
just given a bag of exploration data and
now we want to try to try to come up
with a good policy for choosing the
action in step two now we can compare
different results and every single line
here is actually a different reduction
so the red line is from Bianca as the
drawers news pieces in 2002 it's using
simple importance weighting the blue
line was a paper that I worked on with
Lena where we're looking at using this
offset tree technique I don't want to go
into details and the Green Line is this
double robust approach that we worked on
at one time
all of these are operating in a
reduction fashion and you can see that
different reductions tend to give you
better performance over time as we
understand better and better how to
solve this problem yeah yeah so I can
skip to that or you can just take it on
pace I'm um you're familiar with
reductions from competition complexity
I mean reductions in that sense but I
mean them in a way which is used for
machine learning it was a couple changes
that need to happen when you go to
machine learning so you need to worry
about statistics which you don't have to
worry about so much in the complex of
complexity notion down ok so let's talk
about the red line which is very simple
so what happens here is you're going to
reduce to multi-class classification so
you have actually going to reduce to an
importance way the multi-class
classification so in importance way in
the multi-class classification you have
a label and you have an importance
weight which influences the loss all
right and the way that we're going to
reduce is we're going to take our
features here and that'll become the
features in the multi class example
we'll take our action and that will
become the label normal class example
we'll have an importance weight which is
equal to R / P R divided by P and then
that gives us a transformation from a
contextual bandit example to a multi
class example that allows to then apply
any multi class learning algorithm we
can run with that and use some sort of
multi class predictor which we can then
think of as a contextual bandit policy
and then we can evaluate its performance
yeah
I mean some of them are two
classifications and limiter regression
I'm flexible
he was the probability of exploring the
action so typically when you in order to
solve these problems because you only
get feedback about the action you take
you need to actually explore
alternatives the way I mean without
context people use things like UCB which
tend to work less well when you have
context because there's a lot of
different correlations to break once you
have context information so typically
what happens is you want to randomize
the choice of action then you need to
record the probability of the action in
order to be bias your estimates
appropriately the context agreed upon in
the RVT example oh yeah so we're taking
the RC v1c cat or not problem so this is
our C v1 is a is an old predict which
category a news article Falls in dataset
it actually has hierarchy
one of the top levels of hierarchy is C
cat which is like business articles and
so you created by a classification
problem out of that which is just C cat
or not and then so the actions are C cat
or not the loss is going to be either 0
or 1 depending upon whether you make the
correct choice
so let's keep going
agnostic active learning this is
something that we started working on a
while ago and our first algorithms were
remarkably inefficient they involved
again enumerate a set of policies
Sanjoy and Daniel worked on the first
reduction here there's several other
reductions that they've been working on
since and if you go and you look at what
happens once you have a reduction you
can actually afford to run the algorithm
and you see that the yes you get pretty
decent results this is with decision
trees I think on I think it's key to be
cup data set let's recall correctly
cutie cup 99 so this is the number of
labels that you asked for let me back up
moment so active active learning is the
same as normal learning normal
supervised learning except we're trying
to minimize the number of labels that we
request that's all this is the number of
labels queried for a super values
approach which ODEs everything for every
unlabeled examples you observed and then
for an active learning approach in
etudes your performance is you know
pretty good as a function of the number
of labels queried
okay so then let's think about one last
one so suppose you want to do just plain
old muscle in the class classification
except you want to do it in time
logarithmic in the number of possible
classes so that's a little bit
challenging and again we have a set of
different reductions the recall on the
tree and the long tree are both two
different approaches for doing this and
we can compare in statistical accuracy
with one against all on these different
data sets and you see that we actually
do better than one against all
physically here worse they're somewhat
worse on these ones this is the big
version of image net by the way is the
20 mm class version so this is also kind
of a fun problem because doing this with
gradient descent approaches which is the
algorithm of the day doesn't actually
work you can't afford to I'm greedy to
sent over a set of K things is order K
okay so you can't be done the
logarithmic time
okay so let's take a moment and kind of
think about what we went through in
terms of different algorithms so I
showed you that learning reductions can
do something interesting for exploration
algorithms for learning algorithms for
prefer just learning in context of
bandits for agnostic active learning and
for a lot of make time there's other
research programs that go on in learning
theory so this sort of the old PAC
learning program where these settings
have not really been addressed much and
then sort of the online convex
optimization approaches and I didn't
know how to express results here but
typically what happens is you make a
bunch of extra assumptions about the
form of the problem and then it kind of
looks like a conditional data problem so
this is like the online convex
optimization version of contextual
bandits which is assuming some sort of
linearize representation and about how
the payoffs work for what question is
the answer yes or no can you get
efficient algorithms using these
approaches for these problems
so you cannot so we don't know how to
get efficient solutions using PAC
learning for these kinds of problems at
least we have not really studied that
with online contact optimization there
are vision to algorithms that are kind
of in the same domain as contextual
bandits or is active learning in active
learning I think in particularly the
most advanced and they're actually
useful in contextual bandits I think
they're actually not very useful people
don't really use those algorithms very
much
and then of course you can think back to
simple enumeration type algorithms right
and init enumeration algorithms you can
you can represent good solutions to
these problems enumeration items like
exp for or take a lot about policy
elimination approaches where you just
enumerate all the policies and start
marking them off soon as you prove their
sub optimal right so it's going to
algorithms can give you a good solution
they can compete with a set of policies
but but they're remarkably inefficient
so they would also be in the know column
I explained how you comparator what do
you mean exactly by London reduction
yeah so I'm going to get to what
learning reductions are in just a moment
he says that that's the question that I
think we should delay
so any other questions okay so so this
is kind of the outline we've done one we
discuss why we might want to get to
reductions they allow us to create
algorithms for settings that would
otherwise very be perhaps very difficult
to address and the question is what is
the learning reduction okay so what I
mean by reduction is something where you
have and our reduction is kind of two
parts you have R and you have R inverse
and then you have your base learning
algorithm right so you have maybe your
goal is to minimize some loss on some
distribution producing examples in the
original domain all right so you have
some algorithm for optimizing some other
loss from some other domain and you need
to translate between these two so you
have some way to transform examples or
sets of examples from the original
domain to the new domain and then and
then you have some way to transform the
prediction predictor that you get out
into the starting domain so that's
straightforward so now the trick is you
want to do this in a way such that if h
performs well on the induced
distribution then our inverse supplied
to H will do well on the original
distribution we need to think a little
bit about what well means
so simplest things you could do is just
talk about errors so you could say look
if they have a small error in my I call
it the base learning algorithm so in l
prime that will imply a small error in
my original problem okay so there's a
couple things which are interesting
about this
the first issue that comes up is that
you could have a reduction which
introduces noise just kind of completely
or wipes out any information about the
problem and then you never achieve the
small L prime error condition and then
okay so it's kind of like false implies
true so you could run into a situation
where you can kind of say anything that
you want so that means that you need to
prove that's actually possible with your
reduction to achieve small error if you
want to think this way that's typically
true for natural ways of doing it the
other thing is that this observation
implies that air ducts ian's are kind of
weak for noisy problems so if we think
back to house lecture he was talking
about imitating the experts imitating
the expert just straight up Lex
imitating not using dagger is actually
an error reduction you can say that if
you achieve small error and imitating
the expert you'll tease small error in
the overall problem is trying to solve
but that's not particularly because that
small error might accumulate and then
you know things don't work so well so we
want to that might want to have a more
refined and notion of or what a
reduction is okay so we can think about
regret reductions in a regret reduction
what happens is you have
the smallest possible error rate subject
to the noise and system and subtract
that off from the air raid that you
actually achieve let me call that the
regret and now our goal is going to be
to map a small regret in the base
algorithm to a small regret in the
original domain that's satisfying that
deals with the noise issue to some
extent still actually a bit of an issue
here does anybody know can you see what
the issue is
she was right there that's a min over
all functions and it seems to be the
natural thing as far as what we can
prove which is related to your work on
on different loss functions right okay
so the MS overall functions that's a
little bit different from what we're
used to in machine learning okay so
that's some implications it means that
if you really want to apply this theorem
the user is kind of responsible for
choosing the right hypothesis class you
need to choose a buff this class which
can actually achieve a small error rate
or it can achieve something very near to
that men so it also means that there's
sort of no notion of information
accumulation in this kind of reduction
so if we wanted to talk about acquiring
information which is essential to active
learning or to contextual bandit
learning you can't quite do that with
this notion of reduction so to this
notion of reduction we think back to the
sort of the static context Atlanta
problem where you had the exploration
information already you can use this
notion if you want to think about the
dynamic problem is actually acquiring
the right information so that you can
learn efficiently then then this notion
of reduction is not adequate okay so you
can go one step further we try to define
an Oracle reduction and here what
happens is let's say we have an Oracle
what's given some sample returns the
loss minimizing hypothesis within some
hypothesis set so now we have a fixed
about to set and so we're kind of we
have a constrained capacity as we did
not have previously and now the process
of acquiring information becomes
reasonable to consider so for the
agnostic active learning reductions and
for the dynamic and EXO bandit reduction
this is the kind of thing that we were
doing and and getting good results with
so are there questions about the notions
of reduction here yeah I have a spit
suppose that you have two different
reductions that you're choosing between
yeah you know and they both Sybil's meet
the requirements and they both have the
same required transformations loudly how
do you choose one based on
experimentation or if you you know
there's something else like so let me go
forward slightly so one thing you can
choose based upon is you can often prove
some ratio between the regret here and
the regret there if you have a tighter
regret often it's a better algorithm
I wouldn't say always empirically I
think there are elements of what makes a
good learning algorithm which are not
always addressed by by a reduction but
by default I would kind of go for the
one which has a tighter regret ratio so
I think so when you're working with
reductions in a positive way so this is
the other big difference from the
computational version of reductions here
we're actually mean reductions in a
positive way it's not like it we don't
prove hardness here we prove easiness in
some sense right now the danger with
proving easiness is that it may not
actually be easy in practice but I think
often it is particularly for natural
reductions
this is addresses part of what makes a
good learning algorithm it gives you
maybe some of the insight that you need
to design so which is going to be very
effective in practice
required some sort of discipline on the
on the part of the person joining with
us to make sure that the problem being
created I think if you want to have a
successful algorithm it requires some
real insight into how you're going to
create things I think that there are
problems of substantial interests with
reductions which I would be interested
in any solution to just regardless of
whether or not it's a crazy solution
because it just it seems very natural
I'll show you one later okay so backing
up what you proved here is that if the
Oracle approximately works or it works
then you have the competition efficient
small online or RIT solution to the
original problem
so this is actually from several years
ago we have a lot of different ways that
we've worked out to do regret reductions
and since then I think we've spent a lot
of our time working with Oracle
reductions to deal with these
information acquiring settings like in
textual baños or or active learning
so reductions are obviously are very
good for programming because reductions
imply modularity and they reply code
reuse this is exactly the kinds of
things do you want in VW which is a
online learning project should be at
tilde reductions are kind of used all
over the place
and it's kind of a default way to
compose different algorithms which means
that VW ends up being able to solve a
lot of different problems so this is an
example of a problem which I think would
be of great interest regardless of how
you can with a solution even if you come
with a crazy solution that might help us
get to a good solution so here's the
problem this actually does have a
thousand dollar reward that has been
around for a while
it's it's a hard problem but if you can
solve this I think that would actually
be very interesting for our for the
purpose of doing machine learning so the
problem is conditional probability
estimation in particular given
distribution be over features and
example and label you want to estimate
the conditional probability of the label
so in particular let's just think about
the squared loss notion of probability
estimation and the okay so this is
straightforward dissolve right
straightforward so far and now the twist
is I want you to do this in time
logarithmic and K and I want you to do
it with a constant regret ratio so if
you take away either of these they're
straightforward ways to do this I can do
this in logarithmic time with a non
constant regret ratio I can do this in
linear time with a constant regret ratio
but getting the two of those together
seems to be actually very difficult
there's some evidence that that one
piece of evidence that this might be
possible is that if the problem is
multi-class classification if we just
want to minimize the error rate
rather than doing squared loss then we
know how to achieve this kind of loaded
m'q time and constant regret ratio
question okay I think it's like the log
squared K
yes this is nonparametric there's no
about this class implied it is just a
pure regret reduction I'm talking about
here there's no cost let me go back when
you talk about regret reductions we say
that the regret is the difference
between the loss of your hypothesis in
the best possible so we call that Bayes
optimal and then we want to think about
how small regret in the Duce problem
implies small regret in the original
problem
yeah squared loss regression is the
natural thing here I think so you can do
to do square blots regression over for
one dimension right
place quite lovely
sceptical but I'm open to consider
possibilities
yes big box which immediately suggests
accessible but I'm not going to consider
so this is this is a cold open problem
to be published some time ago probably
the almost decade ago now I would really
like know the answer and I'm still quite
willing to pay the reward is from you
yes I will pay to know the answer to
this question
all right so I talked about the content
in this paper and I this is a large
number of citations to a lot of work
that I consider reductions that are not
even my work which are in this paper so
if you want to go and kind of get the
long form of what I talked about this is
the place to go and look and think
carefully about what exactly is a
reduction and how you can get $1,000
other questions thank you